[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my engine's on fire
request permission to switch on the fire
extinguishing system your engine would
immediately shut down
there isn't denied the
feet and begin knowledge sequence copy
that
did you run the pre-flight checklist
marcolov i'm talking to you
is the locking pin now
what the hell is going on
[ __ ] he killed the engine
what the hell drive to the landing strip
now yes sir
sir the committee is arriving what which
committee general coming in
he's trying to restart the engine
[Music]
come on
alexis
you lazy [ __ ]
commodore general commander of the 294th
division at your seventh please
what just happened here are you working
on the
circus act with some special effects
alexi
alexa are you okay why didn't you use
the ejector seat
here better eye this
and how are you going to explain
i'll just explain that i wanted to to
save this expensive soviet
[Music]
we will of course investigate what
happened who is the pilot
lieutenant leonard i'll tell him what's
what
man's completely insane
[Music]
no i want you to give him to me
insane is exactly what we're looking for
so
[Music]
you